les hôpitaux américains sont déjà
surchargés mais les hôpitaux de new york
vont devoir faire face depuis le 1er
juillet un nouveau rush celui des femmes
qui veulent se faire avorter on était
depuis le 1er juillet l'avortement pour
la première fois aux états unis a été
légalisé dans l'état de new york
l'égalisation suivant des normes
extraordinairement libéral qui risque de
faire de new york la capitale de
l'avortement amérique seule limite le
prix cela en coûtera tout de même au
minimum de 1500 francs par opération
inutile de dire que cette mesure a fait
coulé beaucoup d'eau c'est un fils
chapitre tragique de l'histoire
américaine a écrit le cardinal
archevêque de new york le cardinal coupe
pendant que l'église catholique
rappelait que tous ceux qui participent
à un avortement sont passibles
d'excommunication cette division des
esprits se reflète dans les sondages 50%
des américains sont encore contre
l'avortement 40% pour et 10 % sans
opinion
parmi les opposants la province l'ouest
le middle west le sud les femmes plus
que les hommes les noix du pl et blanc
des catholiques et les juifs plus que
les protestants parmi les favorables les
grandes villes de l'est en particulier
la bourgeoisie libérale
l'agenais et du
7e division d esprit se retrouve au
niveau du corps médical habitué à donner
la vie et non pas à pratiquer des
avortements j'ai interviewé pour vous un
gynécologue amérique quelle est votre
opinion là dessus
à vrai dire ce sera d'après moi un vrai
désastre nous sommes même à présent que
enfin l'histoire n'avait pas comme un
fait nous sommes submergés de demandes
pour avortement
je ne vois pas où nous pourrons
mettre ces gens là au plan de vie
hôpital au spectre hospitalisation ou
bien chambre ou bien
simplement ce sera vraiment un désastre
nous n'avons pas assez de nos facilités
ne sont pas assez
grandes pour nous permettre de faire
votre le nombre d'avortements je suis
[Musique]